what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have actually some good
news when it comes to the recent news
about Jonathan Majors now if you're not
aware Jonathan Majors was recently
arrested he was arrested because he
allegedly assaulted his girlfriend in a
cab he was arrested and the report says
that he went with the police without any
fight whatsoever he didn't try to resist
arrest he didn't cause a huge scene and
right after his lawyer issued a
statement that said that he was actually
the victim here and that they looked
forward to clearing his name then a lot
happened not too long after that reports
came out that there was a video that
could prove Jonathan Majors was innocent
although that video has not been
released to the public yet then some old
colleagues that he had worked with in
the past came out and said that
basically he was a nightmare to work
with and that he was a really bad person
now we're waiting till all of the
evidence comes out to really say
anything about this case because people
complain about actors being really hard
to work with and them being terrible all
the time we really need more about the
situation to come to light as far as the
arrest is concerned we have some pretty
big news today that is actually evidence
that is for Jonathan Majors kind of
being a victim here now we're not all
entirely sure what his lawyer meant by
him being the victim but like I
mentioned today's report kind of
contradicts what his girlfriend told the
police according to the NYPD according
to New York police sources they told ABC
that the actor Jonathan Majors actually
called 9-1-1 because of concern or his
girlfriend they said that Jonathan
Majors called 9-1-1 over concerns about
his girlfriend prior to his arrest for
alleged assault so all we knew before is
that the cops were called because
apparently Jonathan Majors had assaulted
his girlfriend but clearly there is a
lot more to this than we thought he
called the police before about some type
of situation happening with his
girlfriend and he called them because he
was concerned for her now this is
extremely interesting especially if you
consider all of the facts about this one
is that when Jonathan Majors had the
cops called on him and the cops arrived
he did not put up any type of fight he
didn't try to make a scene and he wanted
it to basically go as smoothly as
possible this could be because he knew
he didn't do anything wrong now it also
could be because he knew he did
something wrong but he could have been
keeping it cool because he knew he
didn't do anything wrong and quickly
after that his lawyer came out and said
he was the victim he didn't do anything
wrong and they looked forward to
clearing his name so Jonathan Majors
could have simply been letting the
police take him without any problem
whatsoever because he knew he'd be out
of jail soon and he knew that the truth
of the situation would arrive and would
prove him innocent that could be what is
happening here now all of the stuff that
came out about him kind of being a
horror to work with we're putting that
to the side for now and just simply
talking about his arrest and the
situation with his girlfriend like I
said until more comes out about that
there's not much to say but as far as
him allegedly assaulting his girlfriend
there is a lot more to this picture now
he called the police before she called
the police apparently because he was
concerned for her now we're not exactly
sure what this means yet but whatever
happened there is a lot more than what
has been reported I'm assuming that his
lawyer is going to come out pretty soon
and they're going to present evidence
that shows that he was innocent at least
that might be their plan so before he
was really presented as sort of a bad
person who assaulted his girlfriend now
we don't know that that didn't happen
yet but with this new report it does
make us wonder what the true story is so
if you want to stay up to date on this
be sure to subscribe to the channel
we're going to be covering it if any new
information comes out we'll be sure to
let you know and in the meantime we
remain neutral until everything comes to
the surface but go ahead and let us know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below please don't forget to like
the video and you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter as well as
always thank you all so much for
watching wolf wolf
beep